[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
مقاتلون فاجنر في وسط باخموت ورئيس
الاوكراني يقيل قائدا عسكريا كبيرا دون
ابداع اسباب
غداه عمليه قريه الحواره واجتماع العقبه
اسرائيل تدفع بثلاث كتائب عسكريه الى
الضفه الغربيه
بعد فطور ساد العلاقه بين البلدين وزير
خارجي المصري يزور سوريا للمراه الاولى
منذ عقد
صحيفه السويسريه تكشف حاكم مصرف لبنان
اودع الاموال المتهم باختلاسها في 12
مصرفا سويسريا
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا بتطورات الحرب
الاوكرانيه حيث قال مستشار زعيم
الانفصاليين
فيسكي قال ان قوه تتقدم داخل مدينه باكموت
مشيرا الى ان قوه الروسيه تسيطر على جميع
الطرق المؤديه الى المدينه واكد كما
كوفسكي ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول تسليما
معدات الى مقاتلها في باخموت لكنها تتكبد
خسائر فادحه مشيرا الى ان جميع الطرق تحت
السيطره الا انه اعتبر انه لا يزال من
السابق لاوانه الحدث عن تطويق المدينه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر اهلا بك رائد وبين التاكيد الروسي
باقتحام مدينه باخموت والنفي الاوكراني
اين تكمن حقيقه ما يجري في المدينه
احمد بالفعل هناك معارك مستعره ليس في
مدينه باقمت وحدها وانما في مدن عديده
اهمها بالامس على سبيل المثال كانت
المعارك اكثر عنفا في مدينه افديفيكا
ومحاوله كبيره لاقتحام المدينه من قبل
القوات الروسيه الفرقه الخامسه عشر كانت
بالفعل يعني تجري عمليات عسكريه كبيره حول
المدينه بعد تطويقها من جانبين التطويق
هناك يعني
يشمل
النواحي
الجنوبيه الغربيه والشمال
الجنوبيه عفوا الجنوبيه الغربيه
والشماليه الشرقيه يحاول الجيش الروسي
تطويق المدينه ويحاول اقتحامها لكنه لم
يفلح حتى الان لكن هناك اسلحه متطوره
تستخدم الحديث عن اكثر من 35 الف قذيفه
وصاروخ تطلق في المنطقه هنا في مقاطعه في
كل المدن التي تجري فيها المعارك على سبيل
المثال مدينه مارينكا دخلت القوات ايضا
الروسيه الى المناطق الاقصى الاكثر قربا
من نهايه الحدود الاداريه للمدينه هو
الثلث الاخير من المدينه الذي لم يسيطر
عليه الجيش الروسي حتى الان تبقى مدينه
باخمت هي الاكثر سخونه تبقى مدينه
المعضله الكبرى حيث تحاول قوات فاجنر
اختراق المدينه من عده نواحي ودخلتها
بالفعل الحديث بالامس عن كيلومترين اقل من
قيل مترين تفصل القوات الروسيه عن مركز
مدينه باخمت القوات الروسيه دخلت من
المحور الجنوبي ووصلت الى المجمعات
السكنيه وسيطرت على عده يعني سكنيه يعني
اسمحلي بمقاطعه واسالك عن ان الخسائر
الروسيه في بخموت كبيره جدا بحسب التقرير
الوارده لكن هذا يدفعني لتساؤل حول
اهميه هذه المدينه بالنسبه للروس ام انها
فقط هي مجرد معبر مهم نحو مدن اكثر اكثر
اهميه
يعني الاهميه لمدينه باقموت هي الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه لا اكثر هي الطريقه الوحيده
الذي يوصل الى المدن الكبرى المدن الكبرى
وهي سلافيان
مدينه سلافيانسك على سبيل المثال هي تحبس
المياه عن المقاطعه المياه مقطوعه في هذه
المناطق منذ انطلاق العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه عام كامل لا تصل المياه الى
المواطنين هنا الا ساعتين كل ثلاثه ايام
تضخ في الشوارع ويخرج الناس لنهل المياه
من الشوارع عبر عبوات ويعني بطرق تقليديه
جدا جدا اهميه مدينه باقمت انها تفتح
الطريق لمواجهه القوات الاوكرانيه التي
انسحبت يعني مناطق جنوب لوجانس كانت في
الاستشارينز وفي
سفر دانيت انسحبت هذه القوات كلها لتكون
في مدينه باقمت
هناك قواعد عسكريه كبيره للجيش الاوكراني
من الطبيعي ان حسم مدينه لن يكون قريبا او
بالسهوله يعني لن يكون اليوم او غدا لان
دائما ما يسيطر الجيش الروسي على ثلثي اي
مدينه او اي نقطه يعني مركزيه للقوات
الاوكرانيه ويبقى الجزء الاخير وهو الغربي
لان القوات الاوكرانيه تكمن دائما في
المناطق الغربيه ونحن في شرق اوكرانيا
القوات الروسيه تتقدم من الناحيه الشرقيه
وبالتوازي مع هذه المعطيات ايضا رائد محور
الغربي
فجرت سدا مهما في منطقه باخموت لمنع تقدم
القوات الروسيه وتحديدا قوات فاجنر هل هذه
الاستراتيجيه مجديه وما زال تتبعها القوات
الاوكرانيه كما كانت تبيعها في بدايه هذه
الحرب لكن ليس مع السدود ولكن كانت تتبعها
في في تفجير الجسور بين المدن والمناطق
الهامه
بخصوص
التفجير او التخريب تخريب اي شيء يمكن اي
معركه بالعالم واي حروب دارت عندما يخسر
احد الجيوش وينسحب من مكان يحاول كل تخريب
كل شيء قبل ان ينسحب من المنطقه التي كان
يسيطر عليها لذلك القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول
يعني
الدفاع الروسيه والسلطات هنا في دنيس تؤكد
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تدمر الابنيه
والمنازل واي محطات يمكن الاستفاده منها
بعد انسحابها ولذلك تقوم القوات
الاوكرانيه بتخريب اي شيء يمكن ان يستخدمه
الجيش الروسي في تقدمه وكان مثلا تفجير
السد قبل يومين له فائدتين اولا عدم
الاستفاده من المياه للقوات الروسيه
والفائده الثانيه هي ان يفيض هذا النهر
ويعرقل تقدم القوات الروسيه وسط التقلبات
الطقس يعني درجه الحراره
ترتفع واصبح الوحل يعم الاماكن هي هناك
غابات يعني المناطق كلها عباره عن مناطق
الزراعيه وغابات الطرق اذا على الثلوج
يكون العمل للقوات العسكريه اسهل بكثير من
التقدم في الوحل الوحل يعرقل الاليات
وكذلك تقدم الجنود شكرا لك من دونيس كنت
معنا مراسل عربيه رائد الاغبر تحياتي رائد
في مرسوم من سطر واحد ودون ذكر الاسباب
اعلن رئيس
الاوكرانيوف من مصيب قائد قوات المشتركه
لاوكرانيا التي تخوض معارك في منطقه
دومباس موسكاليوف شغل منصبه بعد وقت قصير
من العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا وشارك في قياده المعارك ضد
القوات الروسيه في شرق البلاد المحاصر ولم
يذكر حساب القوات المشتركه على فيسبوك او
تويتر شيئا عن اسباب الاقاله حتى الان
في هذه النشره وهل توضحت اسباب اقاله قائد
القوات المشتركه الاوكرانيه من قبل رئيس
الاوكراني
صباح الخير حتى هذه اللحظه لم تعلق وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه ولا هيئه الاركان على
يعني قضيه اقاله رئيس القوات المشتركه في
شرق اوكرانيا وما يتداول او ما يعني من
خلال مصادرنا في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ان هذه الاقاله ليست لتقصير او لعمل او
لاي فساد بل لتغيير عمل وضخم جديد في
القوات المشتركه التي تقاتل في نقاط
اساسيه ورئيسيه وهي التي تتحكم بمحور
دونيست ومحور الذي يعتبر الاكثر لان
القوات الروسيه تحاول يعني السيطره
واحتلال كامل المساحه الجغرافيه لمقاطعه
دونس يعني خلال الساعات 24 المقبله سيتم
تعيين قائد جديد لهذه القوه وهي القوه
التي تدوم الجيش الاوكراني الحرس القومي
الشرطه الاوكرانيه والكتائب التي تقاتل
تحت يعني القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه لذلك
لا وجود على اي تقصير او اي يعني عمليه
فساد يعني اقاله بسبب مشاكل ولكن كما
يتداول انه الان يعني يجب ان تتغير طبيعه
العمليات العسكريه خاصه نحن نرى يعني خلال
الفتره الماضيه خلال الشهرين او ثلاثه
اشهر الماضيه تعاني القوات الاوكرانيه
بشكل كبير في محور ضخمه وقبلها محور
السويدار والجيش الروسي يضع كل ثقله في
تلك المنطقه في محاوله لاحتلال تلك يعني
المقاطعه والوصول الى الحدود الجغرافيه
لمقاطعه قبل بدا الهجوم الاوكراني الذي
يعد له خلال الاسابيع الاربعه المقبله طيب
اقاله قائد القوات المشتركه تاتي بعد ايام
او اسابيع من حمله اقالات واستقالات عصفت
بالحكومه الاوكرانيه كما المحت قبل قليل
محمد لكن السؤال هنا حول
التحقيقات التي تجرى مع هؤلاء المتهم الى
اين وصلت وما مصيرها الى المتهمين ايضا
نعم يعني بحسب مكانه يتداول انه كان هناك
حديث عن اقاله وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ما
ظهر ان يعني الرئيس الاوكراني والحكومه
الاوكرانيه لا تزال متمسكه
التي لا يتحمل مسؤوليه اي يعني بعض
الملفات التي تم طرحها خاصه ان الرئيس
الاوكراني قد اعطى يعني قبل شهر من الان
اوامر للمخابرات واجهزه مكافحه الفساد
للضرب يد من حديد على جميع مكان الفساد
التي يعني يعني كانت تتدخل او كانت تلعب
دور في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ووزارات
اخرى مثلا وزاره الاشغال يعني تم اقاله
مساعد وزير الاشغال وعدد من المسؤولين
الكبار ما يتداول نعم يعني كان هناك بعض
الملفات التي كان من الممكن ان تضر بسمعه
اوكرانيا خاصه في بعض يعني المنظمات
الدوليه والدول التي قدمت مساعدات الى
اوكرانيا كانت تقول هذه الدول ترسل تقارير
الى اوكرانيا ان المساعدات لا تصل الى
مستحقيها وانه يتم المتاجره ببعض يعني
لذلك الان هناك حمله فساد حمله مكافحه
فساد كبيره في اوكرانيا في معظم الاجهزه
الاوكرانيه ووقد بدانا يعني نحن كمواطنين
في اوكرانيا بدانا نشعر بجديه العمل
لاغلاق جميع مكان الفساد في السلطات
الاوكرانيه في كامل الاجهزه وهذا ما يدفع
ايضا حول الراي العام الاوكراني المكتوي
بنار هذه الحرب يعني كيف ينظر الى ويتابع
ايضا هذه التغييرات وتطورات على صعيد
قيادته السياسيه والعسكريه محمد يعني ما
نراه ومن خلال جميع وما نتواصل معهم بشكل
يومي اولا هناك تاييد كامل وشامل بالليل
رئيس الاوكراني وثقه كامله يعني الجيش
الاوكراني يعني اين تكلمت مع اي شخص تتكلم
يقول لك نحن نثق في فكره الجيش الاوكراني
بعقيده الجيش الاوكراني وما يفعله هو
الجيش هو الذي يحمينا وايضا يشدون على يد
الرئيس الاوكراني ولا كان هناك يعني بوادر
معظم البرامج الاوكرانيه كانت تتحدث ان
الجميع يجب ان يتكاثف ويقف الى جانب
السلطات الاوكرانيه لمكافحه الفساد لان
الفساد لا يطال فقط سمعه اوكرانيا بل يؤثر
بشكل كبير على السكان الذين يعانون من
ظروف اقتصاديه صعبه ولا ننسى الفتره
الماضيه يعني المشاكل التي مرت بها والتي
تحملها الشعب الاوكراني منها قطاع التيار
الكهربائي من توقف شبكات التدفئه من
انهيار بسيط للعمله الاوكرانيه من ارتفاع
نسبه البطاله بسبب بسبب الازمه الاقتصاديه
التي تاثرت في العمليه العسكريه يمكن
القول انه نسبه البطاله زادت الى بالمئه
عن النسبه الماضيه لذلك عدد كبير وكما قال
رئيس الوزراء الاوكرانيا هناك ثلاثه
ملايين وظيفه يعني خسرتها اوكرانيا خلال
هذا العام بسبب الاعمال العدائيه وايضا
هناك بعض الشركات الكبرى التي اقفلت
مراكزها وشركاتها شكرا لك كنت معنا الصحفي
محمد البابا تحياتي
وقع رئيس الاوكراني على مجموعه جديده من
العقوبات الشخصيه التي تستهدف
277 شخصيه روسيه واثنين وتسعين كيان
قانونيا روسيا تضم القائمه افرادا يزعم
بطوارطهم في اختطاف اطفال اوكرانيين
بالاضافه الى جميع الذين يساعدون في دعم
المرتزقه الذين يقاتلون ضد اوكرانيا كما
شملت العقوبات رياضيين روسا وممثلين اظهر
دعما عاما للحرب
[موسيقى]
هذا وسجل تقرير مكتب المدعي لعام
الاوكراني عشرات الالاف من جرائم حرب
وجرائم عدوان ضد الانسانيه تتهم اوكرانيا
بل تتهم اوكرانيا روسيا بارتكابها وافاد
مكتب المدعي الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه
ارتكبت نحو 72 الف جريمه حرب وجرائم عدوان
في اوكرانيا منذ بدايه العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في فبراير من العام الماضي هذا
وقال مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ان
موقف الصين من الحرب في اوكرانيا يضعها في
موقف محرج دوليا وان اي دعم لروسيا
بالسلاح ستكون له تكاليف حقيقيه كما اشار
الى ان الاداره الامريكيه ليس لديها دليل
على ان الصين تقدم الدعم العسكري للجيش
الروسي في اوكرانيا وبخصوص عمليه تزويد
الجيش الاوكراني بدبابات ابرامز اكد
صليبان ان اداره الرئيس الامريكي لم توافق
على توريد الدبابات الا بعد ضغط المانيا
حيث ان بايدن بالاساس رفض ارسالها لانها
ليست مفيده مساحه المعركه
شدد وزير الخارجيه المجري بيتر سيارته على
ان فرض المزيد من العقوبات على روسيا
ومواصله توريد الاسلحه الى كييف لن يوقف
النزاع في اوكرانيا وقال في مقابله مع
وكاله نوفو الروسيه ان المسؤوليه الرئيسيه
للمجتمع الدولي يجب ان تكون احلال السلام
وانقاذ حياه الناس مشيرا الى ان ذلك لن
يحدث الا باجراء حوار عقلاني واضاف وزير
خارج المجر ان تفجير خطين يجب اعتباره
عملا ارهابيا ويتم التحقيق فيه
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
اسرائيل تكشف عن وثيقه المسار السري
الايراني لتمويل ميليشيات حزب الله
اللبناني
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد كشفت اسرائيل
وثيقه عن المسار السري الذي تتابعه ايران
لتمويل حزب الله اللبناني للالتفاف على
منظومه العقوبات وجاء الكشف عن المسار
الذي اطلق عليه مسار الذهب بعمليه مشتركه
من ايات الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه ووزاره
الدفاع بدات في العام 2018 وبحسب الوثيقه
فان ايران تبيع لفنزويلا النفطا لتلتفع
العقوبات مقابل سبائك ذهب بل مقابل سماءه
ذهب ليقوم فريق القدس التابع لحرس الثوري
وحزب الله بارسال الذهب بطريقه غير مشروعه
من فنزويلا الى ايران حيث يتم تحويله الى
اموال في تركيا ودول اخرى في اوروبا
الشرقيه وسوريا قبل ان تذهب هذه الاموال
الى حزب الله لتمويل انشطتهم في سياق اخر
كشفت وسائل الاعلام المحلي عن تسجيل حالات
تسمم لمئات الطالبات في مدينه قم
الايرانيه بهدف اغلاق مدارسهن وانه تم
ادخاله عدد منهن الى المستشفيات لفترات
واجهزه وبحسب وسائل الاعلام فان حوادث تسم
دفعت الاهالي للتجمع امام مجلس المدينه
للمطالبه باضاحات من قبل السلطات قبل ان
تعلن وكاله انباء ايرنر رسميه ان وزارتي
الاستخبارات والتعليم تتعاونان للكشف عن
مصدر التسمم معتبره ان التصميم كان متعمدا
بهدف اغلاق مدارس البنات
يسود توتر كبير شماليه الضفه الغربيه غداه
اعتداءات المستوطنين الانتقامي على قريه
حواره جنوب نابلس حيث قتلوا فلسطينيا فيما
اصيب نحو مئه وقام نحو 400 مستوطن بحرق
ثلاثين منزلا ومحلا تجاري بشكل كامل كما
شدد الجيش الاسرائيلي عمليه التفتيش على
الحواجز في محيط نابلس ودفع كتيبتين
اضافيتين الى شمال الضفه الامر الذي جعل
السلطه الفلسطينيه تطالب بحمايه دوليه
الفلسطينيين فيما ادانت الولايات المتحده
عمليه حواره واعتداءات مستوطنين التي
تلتها ويرى مراقبون ان العقبه الاساسيه
التي تنتظر مخرجات قمه العقبه الامنيه هي
التصعيد على الارض بوتيره متسارعه
مشاهدينا في مدينه العقبه الاردنيه تعهد
مسؤولون فلسطينيون واسرائيليون في ختام
اجتماع هو الاول من نوعه منذ سنوات
تعاهدوا بخفض التصعيد على الارض ومنع
المزيد من العنف من جهتها رحبه الولايات
المتحده الاحد بالتزام الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين
مشيره الى ان التطبيق سيكون حاسما
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اللحظه يلا
[تصفيق]
ومن رام الله مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه خالد القاسم اهلا بك خالد وهل عاد
الهدوء الى قريه الحوار بعد هجوم
المستوطنين عليها يوم امس
يعني لا يمكن ان نصفه بالهدوء الجيش
الاسرائيلي منع اصحاب المحل التجاريه في
مدينه حواره من فتح ابواب محلهم لمده
ثلاثه ايام تجمعات
للمستوطنين في كل مكان تحضيرا لجنازه
المستوطنين الذين قتل يوم امس والتي
ستكون في القدس عند حوالي الساعه الثانيه
بتوقيت فلسطين
التربيه والتعليم في جنوب نابلس عطلت
المدارس خوفا على حياه
التلاميذ والمدرسين في المنطقه الوصول الى
مدينه نابلس والى بلده حواره اصلا
شبه مستحيل لان كل الطرق في محيط المدينه
مغلقه حيث تجري
قوات الامن الاسرائيليه سواء كانت الجيش
او المخابرات الاسرائيليه عمليات بحث
واسعه
المنفذ العمليه التي ادت الى مقتل
المستوطنين يوم امس في حواره بالمجمل كان
هناك العديد من الاعتداءات من قبل
المستوطنين على ممتلكات الفلسطينيين من
جنين حتى
الخليل لكنها تركزت في بلده
حواره حيث احرق المستوطنون 30 منزلا
وحضائر اغنام اضافه الى خمسه عشر مركبه
وثلاث ساحات تستخدم
لتجميع السيارات غير الصالحه للاستخدام
ويستخرج منها بعض القطع هنا في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه يسمونها مشاطب للسيارات تم حرق
ثلاثه مشاطب للسيارات اللافت ان هناك
تصريحات
لتسبيكا فوجل وهو رئيس
لجنه الامن القومي في الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
يتفاخر بما قام به المستوطنون
امس ويقول يجب ان نرى المزيد من الكره
الفلسطينيه
تحترق على عكس ما تم تصريح به يوم امس في
مدينه العقبه من قبل المسؤولين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين بمحاوله خفض
العنف ومحاوله
ويتناقض ايضا يتناقض ايضا خارج مع تصريحات
والتي دعا فيها المستوطنين لعدم اخذ او
تطبيق القانون بايديهم هل يعكس ذلك حاله
بالانقسام داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه حول
التعاطي مع الفلسطينيين في هذه المرحله
يعني ربما هي من باب الدبلوماسيه يتحدث
نتنياهو لكنه ايضا ادلى بتصريحات تعاكس ما
تم الاتفاق عليه في العقبه قال بان
الاستيطان
سيستمر في البناء بحسب الخطط الموضوع له
لا تغيير على سياسه الحكومه
فيما يتعلق في البؤر الاستيطانيه هذا
الصباح بن جفير موجه رساله الى بنيامين
نتنياهو
لاعاده المستوطنين الى بؤره افيتار كربه
مدينه نابلس والتي كانت اخليت قبل فتره
واخليت الليله الماضيه عندما عاد
المستوطنون اليها اليوم
سوف يعقد اجتماعا لحزبه في هذه المستوطنه
ويدلي بتصريحات مؤيده للاستيطان من هناك
كل هذا يتناقض مع ما تم الاتفاق عليه او
ما اعلن الاتفاق عليه في
قمه العقبه الخماسيه يوم امس شكرا لك من
رام الله كنت معنا مراسل العربيه خالد
القاسم تحيه خالد
بعد فشل الوصول الى اتفاق بشان اليه لخروج
المرتزقه من ليبيا كشفت مصادر العربيه
المقترح مصري اوروبي وبتوافق امريكي
يتناول اليه لتدريب الجيش الليبي واعاده
هيكلته بشكل كامل ووفقا للمصادر فان
المقترحه يتضمن تدريب القوات الليبيه في
الخارج مع توفير دورات تاهيليه لمكافحه
الارهاب والتعامل مع حرب العصابات فضلا عن
ارسال مستشار عسكريين لتدريب الجيش الليبي
والهجز والاجهزه الامنيه ووفقا للمصادر
فان العمل على وضع استراتيجيه كامله
لتاهيل القوات الليبيه سيكون على عده
مراحل في مقترحات مصر ان تنفذ المرحله ان
تنفذ المرحله الاولى خلال شهرين على ان
يكون القرار النهائي من دول مجموعه
الاتصال خلال اسابيع قليله
حيث ستقدم كل دوله رؤيتها حول كيفيه العمل
على تهي القوات وخطتها والوقت المتاح
لتنفيذها
نشاطها مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
بريطانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي يضعان اليوم
اللمسات الاخيره على معاهده
وصل وزير خارجيه المصري كما ذكرنا
مشاهدينا سامح شكري الى مطار دمشق الدولي
في اول زياره من نوعها منذ عام 2011 وكان
في استقباله وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل
المقداد كانت مصادر قاره العربيه الى
القاهره تعمل على اعاده ترتيب العلاقات مع
سوريا واتخذت قرارا بتوسيع العلاقات معها
واشارت الى ان زياره وزير خارجيه مصر
لدمشق تهدف لتنسيق التعاون في ملفات عده
ابرزها الامنيه وتحدثت المصادر عن ان
القاهره سترسل وفودا الى دمشق لاحقا
لتوسيع قاعده الزياره بينهما المصادر
اضافت ان القاهره تحاول اقناع واشنطن
بتخفيف العقوبات عن سوريا
تحدي يواجهه الرئيس التركيب اردوغان اذهب
لمواجهه تداعيات زلزال السادس من فبراير
لاعاده اعمار البلاد بالتزامن مع الوضع
الاقتصادي المزري الذي تمر به تركيا
والانتخابات العامه التي باتت على الابواب
نتابع
تداعيات زلزال السادس من فبراير ما تزال
مستمره لتظهر اثارها بشكل واضح على حكومه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ومستقبله
السياسي موجها تحديا ايواء اكثر من مليون
ونصف المليون
بعد ان تهدمت منازلهم
وعود اطلقها اردوغان لاعاده اعمار البلاد
خلال عام الا ان الضرر طال اكثر من 160
الف مبنى منها
520 الف شقه بينما يتوقع الخبراء ان
تستغرق العمليه سنوات عده وان وعود
اردوغان تحولت لتحد خلال الحمله
الانتخابيه لحزبه المقبل على الانتخابات
العامه في مايو المقبل
اضرار ماديه وصلت قيمتها الى 25 مليار
دولار في تركيا بحسب بنك جي بي مورجان
الامريكي ستتحملها الحكومه التركيه
وتقديرات اخرى تشير الى اكثر من ذلك الرقم
لتكون المساعدات الدوليه التي تقدمها
الدول والبنوك والمنظمات العالميه هي
المصدر الحالي الوحيد لتمويل خطه اعاده
الاعمار
كارثه الزلزال سبقها زلزال اقتصادي اذ
يتجاوز حجم التضخم الحالي في تركيا
57% والذي يسوء وضعه بعد تعطل المعامل
والشركات وايقاف التداول في البورصه
التركيه
استطلاعات رايا تشير الى تراجع شعبيه حزب
العداله والتنميه في المناطق المنكوبه
واصوات شعبيه غاضبه تعلو اصوات الناخبين
بسبب بطء الحكومه لارسال فرق الانقاذ وعدم
الاستجابه الفوريه في بعض المناطق
يتزامن كل ذلك مع القاء اللائمه على
قوانين البناء والمقاولين والتي ساهمت
بارتفاع عدد الضحايا عمر العربيه
القضاء التركي يوسع دائره تحقيقاته بشان
حجم الدمار الذي خلفه الزلزال الذي ضرب
جنوبي البلاد خليل ابن المدينه المنكوبه
هاتاي نجم مع اسرته لكن بيته سيهدم ضمن
هذه البنايه المتصدعه رغم انها شيدت حديثا
هذا هو بيتي لا يمكنني الدخول الى البنايه
التي شيدت قبل 12 سنه فقط تضررت كثيرا
بسبب الزلزال وسيتم هدمها اذا كان هناك
تقصير من المقاولين والمشرفين على بنائها
فيجب ان يحاسبوا على ذلك اما الجد محمد
فقد استسلم للامر الواقع بيته الذي كان
مؤلفا من اربعه طوابق انهار وتسبب في مقتل
13 من افراد عائلته ابني اوكانتي وبنتي
وبنتي وبنتي
وابني وزوجتي اتوفوا اولاد اولادي اثنين
واحد 15 واحد 16
انتقلوا الى رحمه الله
رقم 14 وكل شيء نظامي بس ايش صار صار
بناء نحو 200 شخص رهن الاعتقال فيما يجري
التحقيق مع مئات اخرين يشتبه بمسؤوليتهم
في انهيار الاف المباني تحت طائله ممارسات
بناء فاسده كما طالت الاعتقالات كذلك
مسؤولا بولايه غازي عنتاب تابعا للحزب
الحاكم وقد تمتد لاخرين
98% من البنايات المتضرره بنيت وفق قوانين
قديمه للبناء لا مشكله لدي اذا تمت محاسبه
كل متورط في فساد الابنيه الاخرى الجهات
الرسميه احصت الى الان تضرر اكثر من نصف
مليون منزل بشكل كامل ما يؤشر الى طول امد
التحقيقات بشانها واتساع دائرتها
كلما تقدمت اعمال رفع اطنان الانقاذ هذه
تكشفت معها حقائق جديده بشان التجاوزات
التي طالت تشييد البنايات الامر الذي فاقم
من اضرار الزلزال وخلف عشرات الالاف من
الضحايا عبد القادر خربوش العربيه
دعت قوه مدنيه في العراق الى تظاهر اليوم
امام مجلس النواب في المنطقه الخضراء وسط
بغداد للمطالبه بعدم تغيير قانون
الانتخابات والعوده الى قانون الذي تعتبره
القوه المدنيه قانونا مفصلا على القوى
السياسيه الكبيره حيث يسعى نواب المستقلون
وقوى سياسيه مدنيه ومنظمات غير حكوميه الى
دعم الابقاء على قانون الدوائر المتعدده
الذي جرت وفقه انتخابات 2020
اعلنت القياده المركزيه للقوات البحريه
الامريكيه انطلاق تدريب بحري في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط يضم 50 دوله واجهه شريكه من
بينها مصر والسعوديه والامارات وذكر بيان
للبحريه الامريكي ان تدريب يشمل الخليج
وبحر العرب وخليج عمان والبحر الاحمر
والمحيط الهندي والمناطق الساحليه في شرق
افريقيا ويضم سبعه الاف فرد وخمسه حتى
منتصف مارس وذلك للتركيز على خمسه مجالات
رئيسيه هي القياده والسيطره المشتركه
والامن البحري والتدابير المضاده الالغام
والانظمه غير الماهوله وتكامل الذكاء
الاصطناعي والصحه العالميه
هذا هو عربه الامم المتحده عن عملها في ان
يخصص المجتمع الدولي اربعه مليارات مليون
دولار لمساعده اكثر من 17 مليون يمني خلال
العام 2023 حيث اشارت الى ان اليمن لا
يزال يشهد حاله طوارئ انسانيه بالرغم من
النتائج الايجابيه الهدنه التي استمرت سته
اشهر في العام الماضي واضافت المنظمه
الدوليه الى ان المعاناه المستمره للسكان
اتخذت ابعادا واسعه النطاق والسبب في ذلك
يعود بشكل كبير الى تداول الاقتصاد
وانهيار الخدمات الاساسيه
وشددت اول متحده على ان المنظمات الاغاثيه
تطلب نحو اربعه مليارات دولار هذا العام
لمساعده اكثر من 17 مليون شخص في جميع
انحاء البلاد
تعيش عشرات الاسر النازحه في منطقه الرحبه
في الريف الغربي لتعز وضع الماساويا صعبا
بعد ان هجرتهم الميليشيات الحوثيه من
منازلهم في منطقه الطوير غربيه تعز نتابع
ليس كباقي نازحي البلده لقد عاشوا التشرد
مرتين مرتين حين هجرتهم الحوثيه من ديارهم
في الطوير الغربي تعز والاخرى حين اقر
مالكو هذه المساحه اقتلاع مخيماتهم لاخلاء
سبيل الارض التي كانوا يعيشون فيها فتره
النزوء
حصل حرب علينا احنا كان القضايا ثقبيوتنا
رحت الطبيوتنا فقعوا جهالنا احنا رجحنا
نجحنا من الطور للرحبه الرحبه حوالي فتره
قليل وقاموا تبهدلوا
رجعنا قالوا
تعامل مؤلم يقولون اشعرهم بالغربه في
بلدهم بل ودفع بهم الى ارض قاحله تتوسط
جبلين في الرحبه غربا نساء واطفال يصطفون
هنا بحثا عن مياه الشرب فقط وشيوخ عاجزون
عن الحركه يجسدون حقيقه الماساه لاكثر من
700 شخص في المخيم هذا
ولا سكر ولا هذاك ولا معانا اي حاجه يسكن
هذا المخيم اكثر من
173 اسره داخل المخيم من غير ساكنين
المنازل وعدد الافراد 7 اكثر من 771 فرد
يعانون من شتى المعاناه في هذا المخيم
فالماء يقلبوه من مسافات ثلاثه كيلو لجوء
اضطراري لمئات النازحين في المخيم الى قطع
مسافات كبيره لجلب المياه والغذاء والدواء
من مناطق بعيده عن المكان الذي نصبوا عليه
المخيمات فالمواد الغذائيه لا تاتيهم
بانتظام من المنظمات الاغاثيه يقولون اما
المواد الايوائيه فباتت شبهها معدومه
هكذا اذا وبوضع ماساوي تعيش عشرات الاسر
النازحه في المخيم هذا ضنك الحياه منذ ان
هجرتهم الميليشيات الحوثيه من منازلهم في
الطوير الغربي المدينه فالحصول على ما يسد
الرمق بالنسبه لهم اهم من تحقيق حلم
العوده الى الديار هل سعيد العربيه من
مخيم الرحبه غربي مدينه تعز
انطلقت في مدينه جنيفر السويسريه اجتماعات
مجلس حقوق الانسان بمشاركه وزير الخارجي
الايراني اكبر حسين عبد الله حيان الذي
سيلقي كلمه شخصيا امام مجلس ياتي ذلك وصلت
دعوات من ناشطين ايرانيين ومنظمات حقوقيه
بمقاطعه كلمته بسبب قمع نظام الاحتجاجات
وفي هذا السياق تشارك روسيا التي انسحبت
من المجلس العام الماضي بناء بوزير
خارجيتها الذي ينضم للاجتماعات لاحقا خلال
هذا الاسبوع
اهلا بك راغده وكيف تبدو اجواء انعقاد هذا
الاجتماع وما هي ابرز الملفات التي ستناقش
او ستناقش
بطبيعه الحال هناك اهتمام كبير من المجتمع
الدولي بقضايا الانسان او بحقوق الانسان
في ايران كان هناك جلسه خاصه لهذا المجلس
في نوفمبر الماضي خصفت لمناقشه وضع حقوق
الانسان في ايران بسبب قمع النظام
الاحتجاجات والان يعني اختار دقيقه ومديره
خارجيه ايراني ان ياتي الى هنا شخصيا
ويتحدث الى المجلس كما ذكرت هناك يعني
دعوات منشطين ومنظمات حقوقيه تطالب بان
يكون هناك مخاطعه لكلمه وزير خارجيه
الايراني ولكن هو على ما يبدو يعني يستغل
هذه الخلفه
ايران مستعده الان للعوده هو كان هناك
كلام في وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه
الى اللقاء بعدد من المسؤولين الغربيين
وبالفعل التقى بصباحا يعني رئيس وزير
خارجيه الموجودين هنا
غير واضح ما اذا كان سيلتقي بالوزراء
خارجيه اخرون لانه وزيره خارجيه فرنسا
وزيره خارجيه المانيا موجوده هنا
متبرك يعني من دون شاب مساله حقوق الانسان
في ايران ستكون يعني حاضره في كلمات
المتحدثين ايضا الوضع في روسيا لانه يعني
رغم انه روسيا قالت بانها ستعلق الانسان
العام الماضي ولكن هناك مسؤوليتي نائب
وزير الخارجيه موجود هنا سيحصل الى هنا
يوم الخميس في هذا المجتمعات خمسه اسابيع
لذلك هو ايضا يعني سنتحدث او سيلتقي
بمجموعه هنا
اليها حول حقوق الانسان وحول
الحرب في اوكرانيا لذلك بطبيعه الحال يعني
اوكرانيا في اوكرانيا
والوضع في ايران وما سيكون على اجوبه
المنظمات الحقوقيه والايرانيه ايضا
للمقاطعه كلمه الماسوع يعني اليوم هل
سيعبر عن هذا الرفض
بتظاهرات خارجه مقر الاجتماعات هل من خطط
لذلك او دعوات ذلك لتنظيم تظاهرات اليوم
او وقفه احتجاجيه بالفعل قد يكون هناك
تجمعات يعني عاده الايرانيين في الخارج
دائما يتجمعون عندما يكون هناك حضور لي
يعني
قبل اسبوع او اسبوعين كان هناك تظاهرات
الايرانيين رغم انه لم يكن هناك اي مشاركه
للمسؤوليه كانت المره الاولى يعني لا تتم
دعوه مسؤول ايرانيولات ولكن كان هناك
ناشطون في المؤتمر وكان بالفعل هناك
تجمعات
للمعارضين لذلك اليوم من دون نشهد
تجمعات منازلي معرضين ايرانيين يطالبون
لعدم الاجتماع
واحده من مطالباتهم ايضا
الانفرد او يعني اضافه على لائحه العقوبات
الاوروبيه
لسحاب هناك يعني الارضيه قانونيه لهذا
الامر
لتطورات هذا الملف من جنيف كنت معنا
ممارسه العربيه راغب شكرا لك راغده
مشاهدينا كشف صحيفه سويسريه ان جزءا كبيرا
من المبلغ الذي يتهم حاكي ومصرف لبنان
رياض سلامه
250 مليون دولار في الحساب الشخصي لرجع
سلامه شقيق رياض لدى فرع
واشارت الصحيفه الى ان مبالغ اخرى تم
ايداعها في بنوك سويسريه مختلفه مبينه ان
التحويلات تمت عبر شركه خارجيه مسجله في
الجزر العذراء قبل ان تنقل لها الاموال
بغرض شراء عقارات في دول اوروبيه
شكلت المساعدات الماليه لبعض الجامعات في
لبنان عامل دعم الاستمرارها بعض هذه
الجامعات يعود تاريخ انشائها للقرن الثامن
عشر من هذه المساعدات ما جاء من خريجينا
قدامى قدموا من احد دراسيه للطلبه بعد
لجوء الجامعات لدولاره اقساطها حفاظا على
مستوى الاكاديمي ومساعدات اخرى اتت من
الخارج خاصه للجامعات الامريكيه والفرنسيه
مع سيمباي الازمه الاقتصاديه نتابع
عالميه عاد اللاعب العراقي الى ملعب
الجامعه التي درس على مقاعدها في لبنان
لكنه لم يعد كطالب جامعي بل عاد كمتبرع
تكفل بتعليم عدد من الطلاب
مبادره تقديم المنح اقدم عليها طلبه
قضاهما وجهات مالحه لمساعده الجامعيين
ودعم المؤسسات التي اضطرت لدولاره اقساطها
مع استمرار الازمه الاقتصاديه جمع ساعدوني
ولدي
الجيل الصاعد الشباب الصاعده وهذا هدفي
ساعد هالشباب الصغار اللي عندها حلم
يوصلوا
المنح اتاحت لمحمد فرصه الانضمام الى
الجامعه اللبنانيه الامريكيه وهي واحده من
الجامعات التي لجات الى دوله اقساطها
لتحافظ على المستوى الاكاديمي خاصه انها
من اقدم الجامعات في لبنان
لكن القيمين عليها يؤكدون ان نسب الطلاب
الذين يتلقون المساعدات تضاعف حتى وصل الى
السبعين بالمئه وبان نسبه ما يدفعه الطلاب
مقارنه مع الاقساط الماضيه هي بمعدل
35% بصراحه
يعني حسب الاهل كيف بيقبضوا هيك بس كثير
صعب كيف عم بيعيشوا هلا وخصوصا انه بتعرفي
كيف عم يطلع في كتير مشاكل للكل التلاميذ
اكيد بزمان حياتنا ما كنا نصرف هالقد على
المنح الدراسيه هالسنه انجبرنا لو ما كان
في مساعدات وما كان في اوقاف بره كانت عده
جامعات سكرت ما فينا نكفي بدون مساعده وما
فينا نكفي على الليره اللبنانيه وما بقى
فينا نكفي على مقدور الطلاب لانه كمان
حالتهم تعبانه
لا تزالوا المؤسسات التربويه تعاني من ثقل
الازمه وهي كغيرها من القطاعات خسرت
العديد من الاساتذه الجامعيين الذين
غادروا لبنان تشكل المساعدات طوق النجاه
لاقدم الجامعات في لبنان بعضها حقق مراكز
متقدمه عالميا لكن الخوف ان تفقد الجامعات
قدرتها على تقديم المساعدات قبل انتهاء
الازمه غنوه يتيم العربيه
مشاهدينا نتابع معكم هذه الصور التي وصلت
لقناه العربيه عن قيام جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي
باعتقال عملاء يتبعون لجهاز الامن
الاوكراني اذا هذه صور مشاهدينا في من
القرم لجهاز الامن الفضالي الروسي الذي
يعتقل عملاء للمخابرات الاوكرانيه طبعا
هذه الاحداث مشاهدينا تاتي بعد مرور عام
على الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
اتهم بلياردير ايلون ماسك وسائل الاعلام
بالعنصريه ضد البيض والاسويين بعد ان الغى
الصحف الامريكيه
الهزليه على اثر تعليقات بمؤلفها اعانت
الامريكيين السود حيث قال مؤلفها سكوت
ادمز ان الامريكيين جماعه كراهيه واذع
تعليقات عنصريه في قناته على اليوتيوب وفي
الردود على التغريدات بشان هذا الجدل قال
ماسكين وسائل الاعلامي عنصريه منذ وقت
طويل ضد الاشخاص غير البيض لكنها الان
عنصريه ضد البيض والاسيويين انفسهم
ونذكر مشاهدينا في ختامها الاخباريه باهم
العناوين
مقاتلون فاغاجنا في وسط باخموت والرئيس
الاوكراني يقيل قائدا عسكريا كبيرا دون
ابداع اسباب
غداه عمليه قريه الحواره واجتماع العقبه
اسرائيل تدفع بثلاث كتائب عسكريه الى
الضفه الغربيه
بعد فطور ساد العلاقه بين البلدين وزير
خارجي المصريه للمره الاولى منذ عقد
صحيفه سويسريه تكشف عن ان حاكم مصرفه
المصرف لبنان اودع الاموال المتهم
باختلاسها في 12 مصرفا السويسريا
يعني نهايته صار اخباريه مشاهدينا كونوا
بعافيه
[موسيقى]